I'm not working tomorrow do you want to
come by in the afternoon I'm meeting the
schedule well we could go to that pool
on Octavia wow
not much of a swimmer so
[Music]
from the outset Jen and Brian's
connection as actors was apparent they
had an instantaneous Rapport as people
they were each deeply connected to their
characters in their lives big good dog
you know you just you just ride okay
yeah yeah Brian is the heartbeat of this
movie and we are both clinging to each
other to save each other from our past
this project was a few years in the
making but then once I really got to
crack open the story I realized just how
much I needed it
in this moment we have that scene which
I always call the baptism scene it's all
about exposure
so good
come on
yes
here we are literally stripping down
James is finally showing her what the
process is of taking his leg off when's
the last time he's actually been in the
pool when's the last time he actually
thought that he could swim all these
different things happen in that
particular scene where over the course
of the movie We're watching each other
chip through the wall a little bit
little by little but but because of who
the two of them are and how they are to
each other we're just kicking the wall
in and knocking it down and I think that
what's great about that scene is that
there's nowhere for them to hide
there's nothing more vulnerable I've
learned than being in a body of water
like I've learned that being in a body
of water kind of leaves you as exposed
as possible but also it brings you this
Bliss
feel like a line too
Antoine
he was sitting next to me
he was in the passage
I kept saying he wanted to sit next to
me in the front seat so
I said no
it was too small and they need to be in
the child see
when I see again
how serious
I thought I was supposed to use the [__]
like that
give him what he asked for spoil
see
um
see anything
I'm sorry I shouldn't have done that
why'd you do it then
I felt so bad for you
[Applause]
it seemed to build into this thing of
water being cleansing
it's like truth serum for both of them
they're very vulnerable and just very
exposed but also having the realization
that this Brokenness is not what we
thought it was your Brokenness is one
thing but don't compare that to mine
you feel bad for me
I'm sorry I didn't I got enough people
feeling bad for me
it's not how I meant it and what you
mean
oh yeah you don't know
what is this
what is what
what are we doing here huh having that
interesting conversations you know
especially like in the case of an
argument where you're thinking through a
person's point of view that you know
isn't how you would see the argument
from and how their past has affected
them and the way that they handle
conflict today and that was amazing to
do with Brian because he's extremely
emotionally intelligent I mean he's just
intelligent in every single way and very
articulate you just assume we were the
same broken people wallowing in it [__]
you [__] you
you think I lied about my brother what
about you
you let your nephew write an right in
the seat that night what else did you
leave out
were you drinking
it becomes the raw scene it becomes
pretty crucial and I remember that being
one of the scenes that we worked on a
lot but at the end of the day what I do
love about James and Oakland is that
there's a release
what's your excuse though
how you treat
friends your family
everybody there just to be escaped from
just be left behind
like they let you down instead of the
other way around
you want to find healing and I think
that that's what Causeway provided for a
lot of us at that time I hope that that
is something that's reflected that you
can go home and you can identify with
someone or several people or even just
with yourself that everything is going
to be okay